now this is what dreams are made up
[Music]
yep joe jonas and sophie turner dressed
up as paulo and isabella from the lizzie
mcguire movie for halloween and hillary
duff had the best reaction it kind of
makes me want to cry sophie instagramed
this picture of her and her husband
dressed up as the iconic singing
partners while sophie's staircase
co-star olivia dejong channeled her
inner lizzie the caption sing to me
paulo sing to me paulo
[Music]
and we can only assume lizzy herself
made joe and sophie's dreams come true
with hillary commenting i'm screaming
with three crying faces under the pose
[Music]
joe posted the same pic too and wrote
have you ever seen a beautiful knight a
line from the movie's theme song have
you ever seen such a beautiful night
[Music]
i could almost kiss the stars for
shining so bright
joe and sophie stepped out for a
halloween party in their italian pop
star duds and kept the disney theme
going joe reuniting with his camp rock
co-star and ex demi lovato why are you
looking at me like that
i don't know
you seem different
good
different even though it's been more
than a decade since it looks like joe
and demi remain friends after briefly
dating in 2010. the two posed for a
spooky selfie and we're all smiles jonas
paired the sweet snap with a purple
heart emoji and lovato reposted it to
her instagram story which begs the
question can we get a camp rock three
already i don't wanna waste my summer at
some camp
i'm shane gray for crying out loud well
in 2017 demi joked about doing an
r-rated version it'd be like american
pie meets disney channel
i love it have you guys for real discuss
this yes we've really discussed this oh
my god please make can we say it right
now 2 18 it's going to happen it's going
to happen our rate of camp rock our
rated camp
[Music]
you